many Americans say they're unlikely to
fly unlikely to fly even after
restrictions are lifted according to a
recent survey that is this comes as one
major US airline considers dropping is
social distancing policy and selling
tickets for all seats as these images
suggest some flights are already taking
off up to 85 percent full but airlines
say they are working to lower the risk
of people getting sick while traveling
Kris Van Cleave got a rare
behind-the-scenes look with one airline
United he's at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
well good morning the FAA is yet to set
any standards or guidelines for this and
the Congress didn't require any in the
cares act so airlines have been forced
to figure this out on the fly all are
requiring masks now on flights and when
it comes to cleaning many of these
changes are expected to be part of a
lasting new normal the friendly skies
that United flight attendant Nick Engan
knew have turned turbulent he's
documenting the new normal of flying for
his video blog non-arab Nick including
his now standard pre-flight temperature
check arriving at Washington Dulles
flyers find a much emptier terminal
fewer kiosks plexiglass shields thanks
reminders to distance and stepped-up
cleaning we are inventing a playbook for
cleaning and keeping things safe every
day we are learning and innovating every
day online outrage over this crowded
flight prompted United to launch a new
social distancing policy this week
alerting passengers if they're on a
flight with 70% or more of the seats
sold the vast majority are less than
half full everyone has a different sense
of what is considered uncomfortable so
what we're trying to do is learn every
day continue to evaluate the travel
experience every day so that we can
continue to provide an environment that
people feel comfortable and safe when
they
before boarding a team of cleaners go
row by row wiping down seats tray tables
knobs anything people might touch then
the plane is disinfected using an
electrostatic fogger also used in
hospitals it sprays a mist that kills
viruses and bacteria they can fog the
entire plane even a big one like this
787 in about 10 minutes
by June United plans to be doing this
fogging between every flight on every
plane
how does fresh air get into the plane
through through these inlets maintenance
managing director Jim hammer says cabin
air is constantly refreshed during
flight and run through a hospital grade
HEPA filter like this that strips out
bacteria and viruses for the passengers
inside they're getting completely new
air how how often 2 to 3 minutes Linda
Bowen and her family are waiting to
board a flight to Chicago after her
mother passed away she admits she's a
little nervous just the people situation
you know being in a crowd if there was
going to be too many people around not
practicing the social distancing not
wearing masks but I found that most are
gone is boarding by group number now
flights are boarding back to front as
passengers get on they're handed
sanitizing wipes Bowens flight had less
than 40 on board before taking off
they taxied passed dozens of parked
planes reminders of the uncertain times
facing airlines and employees like
flight attendants making
I think people are ready to get out
again now the debate over how many
people should be on a plane continues at
least two members of Congress have
suggested it should be capped the Flyers
rights crew filed an emergency petition
with the FAA to limit it to half but
airlines say they need planes to be
about 70% full in order to be profitable
right now the airline's say they're
averaging 31 passengers per domestic
flight but their numbers are trending up
in the last couple of weeks Anthony it's
a real dilemma for the airlines Chris
it's good that they're putting out this
information about what they're doing to
make the plane safer but as the
gentleman in your story pointed out
everybody's comfort level is different
absolutely that's one of the big
questions how do you define too crowded
now I think everyone's definition has
changed yeah all right Chris thank you
very much